OWN PARTY NOT HAPPY WITH WHAT
SHE SAID, BRYAN LLENAS LIVE IN
MEXICO CITY WITH THAT,
THANK YOU.
>> Sandra: LET’S BRING IN
FORMER AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED NATIONS NIKKI HALEY,
AMBASSADOR, WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THERE’S SO MUCH TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT, WE WILL START OFF WITH
THE BORDER BECAUSE THIS
BRAND-NEW INTERVIEW WITH KAMALA
HARRIS, SITTING DOWN WITH LESTER
HOLT IN GUATEMALA AND HE ASKED
HER VERY FRANKLY WHY SHE HAS NOT
YET, 76 DAYS IN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER CRISIS GONE TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HERE WAS THE EXCHANGE.
>> AT SOME POINT...
WE ARE GOING TO THE BORDER,
WE’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER, WE’VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN’T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN’T BEEN TO EUROPE,
YOU KNOW, I DON’T UNDERSTAND THE
POINT THAT YOU’RE MAKING.
>> TED CRUZ SAID SHE LAUGHED IT
OFF, WHY WILL SHE NOT COMMIT TO
A DATE AND TIME TO VISIT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> SANDRA, THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
IS, CLEARLY SHE IS FEARFUL BUT
KAMALA HARRIS WAS GIVEN ONE JOB,
ONE JOB AND THAT WAS TO DEAL
WITH THE BORDER AND ANY LEADER
KNOWS YOU CAN’T FIX WHAT YOU
CAN’T SEE.
SHE HASN’T BEEN ON THE GROUND,
SHE HASN’T TALKED TO BORDER
PATROL, SHE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE.
SHE SAYS SHE WANTS TO GO TO THE
ROOT CAUSE AND THEN SHE BRINGS
UP EUROPE.
NO ONE HAS GIVEN HER THE JOB OF
EUROPE, SHE’S GOT THE JOB OF THE
BORDER AND I APPRECIATE THAT
SHE’S GOING TO GUATEMALA, I
APPRECIATE SHE’S GOING TO MEXICO
BECAUSE BOTH OF THOSE LEADERS
SAY THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS THE REASON
THEY ARE HAVING ALL THESE
PROBLEMS OF THE BORDER.
THIS IS THE SAME WOMAN THAT
LITERALLY TWEETED OUT "COME ONE
COME ALL, WE ARE OPEN FOR
EVERYONE."
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THAT AND NOW SHE’S GOING TO SAY
DO NOT COME.
YOU KNOW IT SAYS DO NOT COME?
WHEN YOU SHOW UP AT THE BORDER
AND YOU REALLY HAD ACTIONS SPEAK
LOUDER THAN WORDS.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT HER FEAR IS AT
THE BORDER BUT CLEARLY SHE HAS
ONE.
I DON’T KNOW IF BIDEN’S YEAR OF
THE BORDER IS BUT HE HAS ONE.
WHAT I WOULD CALL IT IS FLAT OUT
AND NOW, THEY THINK THAT IF THEY
DON’T GO IT WON’T BE REAL.
IT’S VERY REAL.
>> Sandra: SPEAKING OF DENIAL,
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS REPORT
THAT FOUND IT POSSIBLE THAT
COVID HAVE BEEN 19 LEAKED ON FRO
WUHAN LAB, I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON FINDING ARE THE
ORIGINS OF COVID-19.
WE HAD MIKE POMPEO ON THIS
PROGRAM YESTERDAY, SOME IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT CONSIDERED IT
NOT PC TO EVEN CONSIDER THIS
WUHAN LAB LEAK THEORY AND THAT
HE WAS POOH-POOHED EVERY TIME HE
BROUGHT IT UP.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU WITH THIS
NEW INVESTIGATION, 90 DAYS,
BIDEN IS LOOKING INTO THIS THAT
WE WILL LEARN ANYTHING MORE IN
THAT IT WILL EVEN BE MADE PUBLIC
PUBLIC?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THEY
SHOULD NOT BE A QUESTION OF DID
THIS HAPPEN IN A LAB, DID IT
HAPPEN IN A WET MARKET, MY
ANSWER IS PROVE TO ME IT DID NOT
HAPPEN IN THE LAB, PROVED TO US,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, PROVED TO
THE WORLD WHERE 3.7 MILLION
PEOPLE DIED THAT IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN IN A LAB.
IF I RESIDE AND I WOULD SEND AN
AMERICAN TEAM TO CHINA, TO THE
WUHAN LAB, THAT’S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WITH ME, HE
SENT ME TO ASK DIRECT QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL AND I CAME
BACK WITH DIRECT ANSWERS.
THESE ARE BIO WEAPONS.
THIS IS SERIOUS, IT HAS BEEN WAY
TOO LONG.
WE NEED A TEAM TO SHOW UP.
WE CAN’T TRUST THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
WE CAN’T TRUST CHINA TO TELL US
WHAT’S HAPPENING, THEY’VE
COVERED UP UP AND 3.7 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
I DON’T CARE WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE PAST.
ALL I CARE IS WHAT HAPPENS NOW
AND THAT MEANS SEND A TEAM TO
CHINA, GO TO THAT LAB AND FIND
OUT IF THE WORLD IS PROTECTED,
FIND OUT WHAT CHINA KNEW AND
WHEN THEY KNEW IT, FIND OUT WHAT
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
NEW AND FIND OUT IF AMERICA
FUNDED ANY OF IT.
WE’VE GOT TO QUIT STALLING ON
THIS, CHINA NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sandra: YOU ARE CALLING OUT
U.S. CORPORATIONS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE GROUP SPONSORING THE
UPCOMING OLYMPICS IN CHINA, U.S.
CORPORATIONS NEED TO SHED THEIR
CHINA HYPOCRISY, FACT IS WHAT
THEY PREACH TO AMERICANS, CEO
SHOULD BE MORE SELF AWARE,
OUTRAGEOUS AND EMBARRASSING FOR
THEM TO SELF-RIGHTEOUSLY TALK
ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE IN AMERICA
WHILE STAYING QUIET WHEN IT
COMES TO COMMUNIST CHINA HAS
TOTAL INJUSTICE.
THAT’S NOT WOKE, IT’S JUST PLAIN
WRONG, YOU WRITE.
WHY DO YOU FEEL COMPELLED TO
CALL OUT THESE U.S. CORPORATIONS
THAT CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS
WITH CHINA AND SOME OF THEM
SUPPORT OR SPONSOR THE UPCOMING
OLYMPICS THERE.
>> I AM VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE SHOULD BOYCOTT
THE CHINESE OLYMPICS.
WE SHOULD GET OUR ALLIES TO THE
BOYCOTT WITH IT, WE SHOULD GET A
COALITION THAT’S ALREADY DONE
SOMETHING, AUSTRALIA HAS ALREADY
ASKED AN INVESTIGATION INTO
CHINA AND CANADA HAS ALREADY
ASKED TO BOYCOTT THE OLYMPICS,
JAPAN IS ALREADY GIVEN ITSELF A
STIMULUS TO BECOME LESS
DEPENDENT ON CHINA, INDIA IS
READY AND WILLING, GET A
COALITION TOGETHER.
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IS A
BUNCH OF AMERICAN COMPANIES
MAKING MONEY OFF OF CHINA.
THEY CAN DO THAT BUT GUESS WHAT?
YOU CAN’T TURN AROUND AND CRY
INJUSTICE, YOU CAN’T SIT THERE
AND CONDEMN OUR GEORGIA VOTING
ACCOUNT ACCOUNTABILITY BILL
WHILE YOU ARE SUPPORTING A
COUNTRY THAT IS WIPED OUT
FREEDOMS IN HONG KONG AND GIVEN
DAILY THREATS TO TAIWAN.
IT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
3.7 MILLION DEATHS, IS
COMMITTING CRIMES OF, TERRIBLE
CRIMES AGAINST WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AND THEY ARE GOING TO
GO AND OVER HALF OF THE SPONSORS
OF THE BEIJING OLYMPICS ARE
AMERICAN, THEN THEY ARE GOING TO
TURN AROUND AND SAY THAT WE’VE
GOT THE PROBLEM?
I THINK THEY NEED TO SHOW US
WHERE THEIR MONEY IS.
I THINK THEY NEED TO SHOW US WHY
THEY ARE GOING TO SIT THERE AND
CRITICIZE AMERICA AND PROP UP
CHINA WHEN THEY’VE DONE ALL OF
THIS.
I THINK IT’S EMBARRASSING INTO A
CRITICAL AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS TO SEE IT
FOR WHAT IT IS.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO TURN YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS UPCOMING
GENEVA SUMMIT, VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN ARE GOING TO
SIT DOWN AND HAVE A FACE-TO-FACE
MEETING.
I GO BACK TO YOUR OWN WORDS,
JULY 2018, AMBASSADOR, TALKING
ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN, THIS IS
CHRISTIAN BROADCASTING NETWORK,
WE DON’T TRUST RUSSIA, WE DON’T
TRUST PUTIN AND WE NEVER WILL,
DO YOU SUPPORT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SITTING DOWN WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
VLADIMIR PUTIN, DO YOU FEEL HE’S
CAPABLE OF BEING STRONG ENOUGH
OR DO YOU BELIEVE HE INTENDS TO
BE IN THIS MEETING?
>> I WILL ALWAYS SUPPORT ANY OF
OUR AMERICAN LEADERS MEETING
WITH LEADERS OF ANOTHER COUNTRY
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY WENT IN AND
HIJACKED, BROKE INTO THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE, DID THIS WITH
A MEAT PROCESSING PLANT BUT THE
THING IS BIDEN IS MAKING SURE HE
GETS A WARM RECEPTION BECAUSE HE
WON A LOT AHEAD AND GIVEN RUSSIA
THE BIGGEST GIFT THEY COULD HAVE
EVER ASKED FOR, LITERALLY
STABBED UKRAINE IN THE BACK
BECAUSE OTHERWISE OIL HAD TO GO
THROUGH UKRAINE BEFORE I GOT
ANYWHERE I’LL SEND YOU WEEKEND
OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES BY ALLOWING
THIS TO HAPPEN, IT’S UNTHINKABLE
THAT HE DID THIS AND THE ONLY
REASON HE WOULD GIVE A PASS, THE
ONLY REASON HE’S NO LONGER
SANCTIONING COMPANIES THAT ARE
PRODUCING THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE IS BECAUSE HE WANTS A
WELCOME RECEPTION.
THAT’S NOT BEING TOUGH ON
POLLUTANT, THAT’S WANTING TO
MAKE FRIENDS.
WE DON’T EVER NEED TO MAKE
FRIENDS WITH RUSSIA, THEY WILL
NEVER BE OUR FRIENDS.
>> Sandra: THOSE ARE STRONG
WORDS RATE AMBASSADOR, I WILL
FINISH BY ASKING YOUR AMBITIONS
TO 2024.
WILL YOU BE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON’T THINK I HAVE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION YET BUT I’M GOING
TO TELL YOU, WE ARE GOING TO